and this is another thing that i think
most of us at the street don't recognize
that in the last 30 years there is
a big revolution in surgery that
most of the procedures are transforming
from open surgery which are the surgeon
is opening the body and performing the
surgery to what's called minimal
invasive surgery
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am being joined by dotan
asshalman the co-founder and cto of the
tour and we're going to be talking about
surgeries and ai
dotan is cto and co-founder of a leading
surgical intelligence platform theater
and has a rich background in
entrepreneurship machine learning
technologies and software engineering
prior to co-founding theater he was
co-founder and cto of computer vision
startup ion and previously served in the
elite israeli 81 unit where he spent
several years as a computer vision team
leader welcome to than
[Music]
astalman welcome to 20 minute leaders i
am really genuinely excited about this
episode we're about to have how are you
i'm good i'm good thank you for having
me here
you know the intersection of ai
technology in general and society
fascinates me beyond what words can
explain whenever i meet an interesting
company that is doing yet again another
interesting intersection of these two
ideas you know that's just amazing to me
and i'm really excited to now dive deep
into the world of how artificial
intelligence is playing in the world of
medicine and surgery specifically with
the actual surgical operations is
something that we can all imagine how
complicated cumbersome and sometimes
disgusting it may be but thinking how
technology may be revolutionizing that
aspect i'm really excited but before we
even get to that walk me a little bit
through your life because you've worked
on a few projects that have a common
thread of doing good for the world so
tell me a little bit about yourself
so my background is in computer vision
mostly i'm a computer vision researcher
and research engineer and manager
i spent around almost seven years in idf
intelligence in 81 units in israel
then i
started my journey in entrepreneurship
and startups i was like a bit out of it
a
consultant for many startups in israel
specifically on computer vision and
always my passion was to
know how to like if you're looking back
in my background in idf so we we did
good we did like we did good by doing
bad to bad people
uh using technology and i try to do
something that is more purely good let's
say and
ion is a good example of it a
lot less of a good business but really
really good uh
something that can be
very impactful and i think that in in
theater we find like the common ground
of both a very big big and strong
business model combined with the
positive impact that we can provide
and so just in two sentences what you
did with ion you were you created a
safety solution for swimming pools
trying to detect drowning using
underwater cameras obviously
using the computer vision
experience that you have from before and
and you know every time we hear about
another drowning occurrence in the
newspaper the heart breaks and obviously
this is a huge problem that you tried
solving tell me a little bit about about
uh you know theater and and what your
what your understanding is of the
medical space especially what is the
pain point that surgeons may be having
today
yes theater started from from the need
and not from the technology and we saw
that
actually from a personal experience of
my co-founder tamir that he is not a
surgeon but a physician and he diagnosed
two
different uh people around the same time
with the with the
uh the need for for with an appendix uh
uh
like problem and they both knew that
they needed an appendectomy
and they both went to different
hospitals around new york
and they got a completely different
treatment one was at home 12 hours after
in recovery and the other almost died
like three times and were like more than
seven days in hospital
and this is like really
a
resonates to us like how much
of a variability there is in healthcare
in general and specifically in in
surgery care
and we started to investigate this
feeling we saw that it wasn't just like
one random example this is something
that happening all around there are huge
differences in performance and this is
like
causing from the
the basis of how surgery is being
thought and performed
er and this is this is the problem that
we try to tackle we wanted to reduce
variability in surgical care
okay so you're talking about variability
in surgical care the translation the
direct translation of that is life and
death right there's variability in a lot
of things in life but here we're
actually talking about you know whether
somebody will will successfully come out
of the surgery and live a happy healthy
life versus potentially not and at the
end whenever we have humans in the
middle we have variability and that's a
that's a common understanding but please
go on i think i interrupted you
no so i think that when you're looking
at what is like what is causing the
variability you are seeing that the the
main cause of availability is
decision making and this is something
that i think most of
us as patients doesn't understand how
like how many decisions surgeon needs to
take doing even like the most
common and standard procedure like an
appendectomy or
a cholecystectomy
and
and i think this is one of the amazing
part that
decisions are not really being
uh
there isn't all there isn't a any
information that being transferred in
horizontal matter there is only your
experience maybe an experience of the
mentor that that help you
during your residency but there isn't
any
anything that is structured that you can
learn best practices from there aren't
best practices in surgery oh really
right maybe what you're actually
what you're actually saying is that by
by horizontal understanding you're
meaning that there is no network effect
of you know the more surgeons you have
the more knowledge you provide to the
next surgeon because it's it's very much
siloed it's very vertical where you're
learning from your superior and your
mentor but you're not learning from your
peers in in a proper way right and now
multiplied by 400 years of modern
surgery and you are getting like huge
differences
in in the approaches
right
yeah
and today when you are talking about on
like how best practices are defined best
practices are defined by asking but by
adelphi consensus so you are asking like
the 10 most prestigious surgeons what
are the best like the best way to
approach a specific situation and they
are voting on something and there are
there is some decision out of it but not
nothing that is really
grounded by statistics and this is
something that we wanted to change we
want to to bring science into surgical
best practices and this is what theater
like this is in general
the mission of theater
and and how i'm as a computer vision
energy engineer
and researcher and entering this uh this
domain is
by seeing the huge opportunity that
there is in surgery
that and this is another thing that i
think most of us at the street don't
recognize that in the last 30 years
there is
a big revolution in surgery that
most of the procedures are transforming
from open surgery which are the surgeon
is opening the body and performing the
surgery to what's called minimal
invasive surgery which are all like
laparoscopic like all of the ex scorpios
of the world or robotic surgery which
means basically that the surgeon instead
of opening the entire body they are
doing like two or three
or up to four
holes small very small holes in the body
they are pushing a
camera and
a two more holes for the for the tools
and the entire surgery is being
performed by the surgeon looking at the
screen instead of looking at the
specific patient and then this is
obviously screaming to us computer
vision computer vision computer vision
so when you're looking at like what are
the decisions that are impacting the the
outcome the decisions are already being
captured by the camera so yeah it's
basically like you're saying this isn't
this is like a lost opportunity there's
so many decisions there's so many
information
that just being being lost and staying
there in their world
and and only thing that like the first
thing that you need to do is like just
press the record button and like start
start to understand better what happened
there and this is where i think this is
like
well a
like starting point for us that we
understood that there is a big problem
there is a big need and also already big
opportunity uh
that the hardware is already exist but
nobody is doing anything with it i love
it okay so before we get to the
technology which is the really cool part
here
consumer experience perspective you go
to the surgeon
what do they say when they're thinking
of this idea of of bringing in ai to use
this do they look at this as a black box
as a competitor because you're talking
about 400 years of modern surgery very
horizontal where they're being taught
that you know their intuition their eyes
their brain their hands are what should
guide the surgery how are they reacting
to this idea that a lot of the decision
making is now going to be replaced by
technology whether it's through theaters
or through somebody else
so when we started it as an idea so a
lot of like eyeballing and nobody
understand how
how it is going to be like but today
right much more common
we need to remember that there are
a
new generation of surgeons that uh used
to be everyone is a visual learner today
you don't like video is overtaking the
entire internet right and
even like in this interview we are doing
using video
and those like this is a generation of
like youtube netflix surgeons also wants
to
uh to
consume their knowledge uh using videos
so it's like more common to them
and we are seeing that they like huge
transformation from
three years ago that we we needed really
to find the early adopters today that
everyone understand that
there are so many knowledge that we can
gain from surgical videos that
you can't like leave yourself out of
this uh this next evolution
okay so so let's dive deep into this
revolution from theotor's perspective
what are you using computer vision for
in in the realm of surgery and how is
this actually going to help make the
surgeries better in the end
yeah so we call it surgical intelligence
this is a term that we have coined and
we are happy to see it
being taken from like other
other companies and conferences
and
it's always cool to being asked by
a customer if we are doing surgical
intelligence which is the world that we
that we defined uh
amazing
so the basic like the basic of statical
indulgence is understanding best
practices but we are we are
doing
a stepwise approach to uh providing our
services
at the basis at the core of the
technology we can take a surgical video
that can be
very long could be like six seven hours
long
and we are we are breaking it down to
the like the most common uh
mom we call it moments the most common
moments in the surgery so we are
breaking into the key steps
which are the the things that the the
specific actions that the surgeons are
doing
events that are more in most cases like
adverse events uh things that shouldn't
happen but happening there in the
surgery key milestones that you need to
a certain needs to get to and we can
detect whether or not you get to the
specific milestones
and the decision-making junctions the
point in time of surgery that a big
decision uh needed to be to be made for
like one one or two options or maybe
maybe more than two
and think about it like on based on this
a
basic
layer of
extraction we are
completely
converting this unstructured wall
footage to something that is much more
structured
and this is allowing us to provide a lot
of services the first service that we
provide and it always like very easy to
er to understand is a surgical summary
so you just got out of six hour long
procedure you want to review your case
you don't have six hours to to watch it
but if what about like just just like in
soccer you can just just watch the goals
and like the main events
so we are we can extract a surgical
summary of like three to four minutes
out of the
uh the entire surgery that help you to
review your case very quickly or maybe
not you maybe maybe your supervisor or
or a colleague that can can help you
and provide you with some feedback
so this is this is the start of it and
we are starting to
build an entire ecosystem around
this core technology that help surgeons
with any step of their daily workflow so
it's from
a pre-surgery you need to prepare for
your surgery tomorrow what about us
showing you similar cases similar
specific events that will help you to
be prepared to this not just for
the causes tectum that you have to know
but on the cause stack to me with the
someone with spiral abdominal surgery
that they have as
obesity like you we have like the
specific characteristics and we can show
you like five to ten minutes of the like
the main things that you need to be
aware of so this is pre-surgery during
surgery we are providing live stream of
the video currently we are not providing
any a
although we techno like in the
technology
from technology perspective we are
already detecting everything real time
we are not providing any indication to
the outside this is uh due to regulatory
reasons at the moment but of course this
is our our goal we want to help surgeons
uh not by providing feedback about their
decisions but helping them when they are
like in the main key points that they
need to they need to make the decision
during surgery but we are providing live
streaming to the outside and helping
surgeons
uh to get advices from from colleagues
and post surgery
the
summary of course
analytics on top of it
and
also helping with a documentation of the
surgery
and then think about it if you have a
once you have this all this analysis for
one procedure
you can provide
other views that can help you in a
department level in a personal level
maybe like seeing your weekly
performance and trends
seeing the department's performance
bottlenecks and everything is very
actionable and this is basically what we
are what we are providing on top of this
basic
uh
quality of extracting those structure
out of the surgical videos
amazing and obviously you know in in the
pre-surgery in the poster regime it
makes perfect sense and you know i'm
already thinking about you know uh
drawing the parallel to the briefing
sessions of the israeli air force or
through coaching sessions out post you
know soccer games where you're sitting
and you're either preparing by watching
previous games of the team or you're
debriefing later to watch what went
wrong and what moves worked didn't work
and it makes perfect sense and i can't
believe that it's not happening yet i'm
yeah go ahead
no it's amazing that you you know you
have any nba player have it but like
less of an important job like surgery
doesn't have any any of those
and they understand like surgeons
understand that you can't like you need
to if you want to improve
you need to to measure and if you want
to measure you want to capture and this
is the thing like getting back to the
like the like the main question if you
are going to a surgeon and tell you i
want to start capturing all of all the
things that you are doing without
providing providing anything in return
so they are getting defensive
but
for them they want this analysis they
want to they they know that if you like
if you can if you if you're not
capturing you can't really measure
anything
pause with me dwell with me for another
minute on on the on the during the
surgery because obviously this is a you
know the most interesting piece
we're talking now about you know the
live streaming and getting inputs from
the outside
i mean what is the vision here at the
end in terms of of actionable insights
during the surgery
and is this something that you know
what's the barrier is this a
technological barrier or is this a
consumer behavioral barrier an adoption
barrier
so it's all of the above i think it's uh
there is the
there is a regulatory barrier that we
can we can put aside this is a process
that needs to be made
i think on technological uh perspective
so although we we are
running everything in real time we have
we don't have the same with the same
performance as we have post surgery of
course
and i don't and even if if we are we we
need to get a certain
level of
confidence that we can really
do like provide this feedback in real
time that i don't think that we are
there yet but we are in the process to
it
and the third you you cut it right i
think that like there is a
a consumer adapter even adoption a
barrier that
and and this is actually the connect to
even what we are doing right now is kind
of like a spaceship for a any medical
profession professional because
healthcare was so like so much in the
past
that uh just providing a
what we are providing right now is like
a huge huge advantage advancement for
them so providing
a
really like ai assisted
assistant doing surgery is
even more than like a specific
technology
and you need you need the the surgeons
to be involved in the process and this
is something that we are doing right now
we are
involving this is how they feel they we
have our customers
they met us before surgery they met they
are meeting us after surgery they are
building their
uh
um
knowledge they are building their uh our
like relationship with our system
that eventually will get get them to
like a specific point that they can
accept the feedback that we are
providing during surgery and even even
if the technology was ready i don't
think that we were able to deploy it in
this year because of those those
problems you need to like
the surgeons in the courses
fascinating and and and i have to put
the context of the whole conversation at
the end that we're talking about an
industry that is all around surrounding
life and death this is not just you know
a
an adoption for better for for better
use this is literally going to change
the the sphere and and i just love the
the understanding of how vertical the
the whole learning environment is and
improvement where you have 400 years of
modern surgery behind you that that has
been this way but but when we're missing
out on the whole horizontal layer of of
this expansion and this and this
knowledge sharing in the time thank you
for the amazing work that you're doing
with well theater thank you for the for
the great work that you're doing with
with ion and uh and and i just love the
the usage of computer vision for these
types of problems i have a few more
questions not about theater are not
about surgery but about about you uh i
want you to take me back to childhood
something that really fascinated you
before computer vision before the idf
it was always technology around
technology i think i always like to
build stuff
mostly hardware actually and maybe maybe
i'm not that old but maybe because of my
age so less less of a software uh
stuff
and
i think yeah mostly like
build stuff maybe like break stuff and
try to build maybe them
that that's muslim and something that
inspires you today
i'm
so
so it would be
too easy to say theater but i think in
general i'm always inspired by
any
so i'm really like like a product driven
or like impact driven person
and i'm i'm an engineer as well but i'm
always fascinated to see
how technology is being used for for
positive impact in healthcare in
agritech in many fields but this is like
the main
the main passion for me
amazing and what are three words you
would use to describe yourself
oh well
um
i don't know i don't know to answer that
um i
i think i don't know if i can maybe i
can do like in in
in a world in one word it would be like
a contrarian
i love it i i absolutely love it and
i'll take it
i think that that's it that's a great
description and i really want to thank
you for
for coming on and sharing with me these
20 minutes um i i'm living very very
inspired so thank you very very much and
continue making a positive impact and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
thank you for having me thank you
hey